[Music]
imagine you're supposed to carry some
goods from one place to another in a
container what type of a container will
you prefer we would firstly think
whether it's light or heavy because
carrying it should be convenient also
being light should make sure that it's
durable and what if you notice that the
container is reacting with the matter
inside that would ruin all your hard
work of carrying it so you also need to
be sure that it's not made up of
reactive material how are we supposed to
find all these qualities in a single
container what material can you think of
when you hear strong and durable yes
what comes to mind is a metal container
that would be ideally strong but wait a
second metals have a tendency to corrode
or rust easily so what should we use
then guess what we have plastic that
comes to our rescue
yes you heard me right plastic is most
of the qualities that makes it a choice
for making several articles and what are
these properties amongst all we take
three most important properties that
make it a material of choice nonreactive
nature
poor conduction of heat and electricity
and lastly strength and durability can
you tell me examples of articles where
each of these properties is used let me
help you with that let's begin with the
non reactive nature first we know that
metals usually get corroded or rusted
easily what does this mean it means that
in presence of air and moisture metals
have a tendency to get physically
degraded or to form oxides but plastics
do not show a tendency like this in fact
plastics do not react with air moisture
or even with chemicals for that matter
as a result no rust is formed hence they
can be widely used to store various
types of liquids and chemicals and where
can this property be applied yes
airtight containers
be made to store food or liquid items
dust as property help us to predict
another important application of
plastics yes in the medical field
because they do not react easily with
chemicals and are non corrosive in
nature bottles sachets and strips of
plastics can be used to store medicines
along with this even the syringes used
are made up of plastic and what about
the gloves used by doctors yes plastic
exists there as well anything else that
we should know the nonreactive property
of plastics is so reliable that it is
used to even make threads that I used to
stitch wounds yes the threads used for
stitches are made using plastic because
it's safe on wounds this was a short
summary about the nonreactive property
of plastics do you remember the next
property yes it was conduction of heat
and electricity let's discuss this
property in detail in the next lesson
[Music]